(click)
(light piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is evitable.
Yet, filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
to the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- So I thought I'd take
the director's prerogative
and spend the first five,
ten minutes going back
in time over some of the
events that lead to the work
I'm going to present.
And also because some of
the people that are here
in the audience are involved in some
of these early phenomemon.
So first let's step
back and go to the 1950s
when the work of many
people had clearly shown
that we shared a common
ancestor with the great apes.
Most likely the chimpanzee
but it was considered
to be this great golf that
needed to be resolved.
In Sarich and Wilson in the
60s immunochemical techniques
and Goodman, Russ Doolittle
here in the audience
and others showed but most of
the proteins were identical.
Sequences are essentially identical.
And Mary Claire King in
her thesis work was asked
to find something different.
And she couldn't find much at all.
So they wrote this famous
paper that said that maybe
the genes are nearly identical.
And the proteins identical,
they're just expressed differently.
And this theory actually
held, believe it or not,
for almost 20 years.
A part of it is definitely true
until Maynard Olson, who is
also here in the audience,
suggested in 1999 that
gene loss may be important.
That is getting rid of a gene
might be just as interesting
as having more a gene or changing
a gene or it's expression.
By some coincidence, actually,
that the end of that year
just before that we
reported the first genomic
and biochemical difference
between humans and great apes.
The first known at the time.
And it was due to gene loss, CMAH.
I'll come back to what CMAH is.
So let's define some of the words here.
Hominin.
Hominins are human ancestors
and our extinct evolutionary
relatives, that is Neanderthals example.
Hominids are human ancestors
and our living and extinct
evolutionary relatives, which
includes the great apes.
So we go back to our diagram here.
There are the hominids.
And there are the hominins.
And we are one of the group of hominins.
So if you go back into
detailed background-
oh before of the aficionados get upset
the branching relationships
here only do not reflect timing.
The branch link does not,
it's just relationships.
And there is one time
point that does matter
and that's the one shown
down there, .5 million years.
Right here is .5 million years.
The junction where the common
ancestors, Neanderthals,
Denisovans and humans.
So let's look at what
happened going up to there
and this is a very complex slide.
But it includes all the known information
except for the last couple
of years from Wood and Boyle.
Talking about all the
different hominins that existed
in Africa until about
two million years ago
when the genus homo emerged
and not only stayed behind
in Africa and spread across Africa
and spread all across the old world.
And eventually gave rise
to us again in Africa.
Homo, of course, had a
wanderlust and wondered all over
the old world, never
crossed the water way.
He couldn't see the other
side as far as we know.
But otherwise, you've heard
of peeking man, java man
and so on.
This probably went on for
about two million years
and finally our own species,
again the numbers have changed.
They change every month now
because of new data coming in.
But the general pattern is true.
Emerged in Africa and
spread out across the world
essentially replacing
all the other species.
Including the species in Africa
with limited interbreeding.
So we had found a pseudogenization,
a gene deletion in
humans and this has to do
with sialic acid,
another word in my title.
So what's sialic acid?
All cells in nature without
exception are coded with a
dense array of glycans or sugar chains.
Here's a classic slide
from in the early days.
He always saw the stuff
sitting on the surface.
But if you look over
here at a mammalian cell
you can see this huge
thick layer of sugars.
Same in the bacterium
and even many viruses
are coated with sugars.
So this massive layer of
glycans which is sort of a dark
matter of the biological universe.
That most people don't study or even
acknowledge their existence.
You didn't see it in any of the
slides in the first session.
(audience laughing)
- So this on the outer most
strip of vertebrate glycans
are these sugars called
sialic acid which sit out
at the tip.
There's a lot of them.
There can be millions and tens
and even hundreds of millions
of copies per cell.
A recent calculation said that
a lymphasite had a density
of 100 millimolar on the surface.
That's right, millimolar.
That's a lot.
And so obviously they must
have a lot of biological roles.
And the story we have been
pursuing is the fact that
there are many kinds of sialic acids.
The two most common ones are
called Neu5Ac and Neu5Gc.
(audience laughing)
- [Ajit] Yes, we have some
rock and rollers in my group.
(audience laughing)
- [Ajit] And Gc is
derived from Ac by adding
one oxygen atom
by this enzyme called CMAH.
And so here's that single oxygen atom.
You may think that's
trivial but that's a single
oxygen atom added to 100
millimolar concentration
of something on the cell's surface.
So that's a big effect.
And what we basically found
was that Gc was missing
in humans due to a mutation in CMAH.
Looking further into this
with Toshiyuki Hayakawa,
Yoko Satta and Naoyuki Takahata
we found, Pascal and I
found that there was this
alu-mediated inactivation
that occurred in this manner
taking out this critical exon
that is fixed in all humans.
All of you have this mutation, homozygous.
And this exercise was also
useful because this allowed
timing by several different methods,
none of which are perfect.
But I won't go into the details of timing.
But all of them gave a time
of about 2.5 to 3.5 million years
where the mutation first occurred.
So we went further and collaborated
with Sevante Paabo and Meave Leakey
back at that time
looking at fossil samples
and the sort of side fraction
from the DNA extraction
we could find only Ac
in Neanderthal fossils.
So we thought that maybe
there was no geno sequence
at the time.
Also missing CMAH.
But then the question came up,
how did this mutation get fixed?
And Pascal came up with
a very interesting idea.
After all, when you get a
mutation if this mutation
is due to a pathogen that is binding Gc
leaving some people with Gc negative,
you're expecting kind of a
polymorphism like you see
in sickle cell disease.
How does it get fixed?
By the time we had mice
with the same mutation
which have a lot of phenotypes
by the way that I'm not
going to go into, human life phenotypes.
So we could do this
experiment that he suggested.
Which was to show that while the rare male
that is Gc negative,
because a large number
of males are Gc positive.
The Gc positive sperm are
killed by antibodies produced
by the female.
In fact, humans serum will
kill chimpanzee sperm also.
And so Steve Springer
actually did a calculation
saying that within 30 to 650 generations
this could actually generate two lineages.
And so the hazard of this
might be the genus homo.
Unfortunately sialic acids
and DNA do not survive
in African fossils.
Samples the Meave Leakey gave
us had no sialic acid in them.
But very recently, this
is hot off the press,
we found that these N-glycolyl
groups, these Gc groups,
actually survive in a byproduct
called chondroitin sulfate
in ancient fossils.
In fact, Meave sent us some
samples from a four million
year old bovid fossil and
we could find GCCS there.
We now wonder whether we
can go back to this theory
and try to improve our
techniques and convince people
to share with us small amounts
of their hominins samples.
If you can do that we could end
up with N-glycol-CS positive
N-glycolyl-CS negative fossils
and this brunch would then
try to break up this big bush
that everybody's studying right now.
And get some lineage out of it.
Okay, what's a Siglec?
A Siglec is a molecule,
a family of molecules
that we discovered and
named some years ago
which through this red domain in the
this is the cell membrane
bind sialic acid.
They have many functions, but
one of their major functions
is the subgroup called
CD33-related Siglecs.
What they basically do is see sialic acid
as self associated molecular patterns.
You hear about danger associated
and pathogen associated
molecular patterns, why
don't you cells attack you?
One of the reasons is they see sialic acid
and say halt.
So the immune cell is stopped by that.
So you can think of it as
brakes on immune cells.
These molecule patterns
are actually widespread.
Pascal suggests that I show this picture
because the picture
speaks a thousand words.
Here's a fresh blood smear
that's glycophorin on the surface
covered with sialic acid red blood cells.
Here's a white blood cell in neutrophil
and you can see all the
Siglec-9 is clustered.
The red cells are holding
to the neutrophils
saying wait there buddy,
you're not ready to fight yet.
And so, of course, pathogens
have taken advantage of this
and it turns out that
no pathogen can make Gc.
How have we lost Gc?
We threw away our best cell signal.
Now we have these bugs of
wolf in sheep's clothing
that are invading us.
And so then we found a
second mutation effecting
sialic acid biology in Siglec-12
and here had fixed genomic changes,
polymorphic genomic changes
and major expression changes
in three of the major categories.
But we're really quite frustrated
because without the level
of molecular biology we could do
we couldn't go much further.
But fortunately many
people are getting interest
in the chimpanzee genome.
This is an article I wrote and baby Papot
photographed by Pascal
Gagneux and Sarah Varki
by Hudson Freeze.
I did get permission from Sarah Varki.
(audience laughing)
- [Ajit] And go Maynard
got excited about this
and actually 9/11 has
something to do with it.
That's a story for another
time and white papers
are submitted we actually
had the first ever symposium
just before the chimpanzee
genome came out.
That's Sarah again with her permission.
So now we have the sequence
the chimpanzee genome
and fast forward now 10-12
years and we could look
at all these Siglecs.
The long and the short of
it is in the circle of life
that Pascal drew for me,
we find rows of Siglecs,
mutations of Siglecs
involving many different parts
of the circle of life.
From cells ranging from sperm
to Gut Epithelia to T&B cells
to Pancreatic Islets and
ROS Production and so on.
The problem was that we
had just one or two genomes
of each of the apes.
There's always this worry,
is it just genome quality?
Is this just chance?
Is just ascertainment bias?
Are we like the proverbial
drunk looking under the lamppost
for the keys?
Fortunately at that time Evan Elchler
and Tomas Marques-Bonet came
up wit great ape genetic
diversity and population history
involving many people in CARTA as well.
So we had access to ape genomes.
Now we could get a reasonable
number of ape genomes,
not as many as humans of course
but still something to work with.
We did that, it turned
out that in fact even some
of the polymorphisms we
thought were fixed in apes
were not fixed, they're
polymorphic, they're not fixed.
So in fact we've seen that
apes don't have many mutations
so this finding over here,
and some of these of course
expression pattern changes is significant.
We've shown you multiple
genome events altering hominin
sialic acid biology and now
we'll come to the actual topic
of the, about the common ancestor
of humans and Neanderthals.
These mutations are all
found in African populations
so they predated the common
origin of modern humans.
Actually a paper just on
line including Tony Capra
I think is here, shows that
genes involved in sialic acid
biology do not harbor at
least strong signatures
of recent positive selection.
So they're of more ancient origin.
Stephane and Kay from Lifesake
showed a new method
and showed that in fact
there's no evidence of strong
selection on these genes
after the divergence of humans
and Neanderthal common ancestors.
So now we can zoom in
here and start looking
at the wonderful data that
Servante Paabo and so many others
have generated on Neanderthal
and Denisovan genomes.
Looking at these sequences
we find that we can find
essentially all these
mutations, almost all of them,
although obviously the population
sizes here are very small
so we don't know if they're fixed or not.
We can find mutations
Siglec-3, 12, 14, 16, 13, 17,
Siglec-12, CMAH.
There's a few other genes
that we're looking at.
As for these expression pattern changes
we've looked at comparisons with chimps
and bonobos and so on.
We don't have all the
possible comparisons.
Something seems to be going
on where a large number
of genes seem to have been
turned on in the human lineage
in many tissues.
What we believe is that
this cluster of genes
in chromosome 19 has
undergone some changes.
Clearly undergone a
lot of genomic changes.
And perhaps, secondarily,
perhaps effecting epigenitics
in transcription and so on.
Also, produce a lot of ectopic expression.
We think of Siglecs and
various other tissues,
but there's a lot more work
to be done before we can
say much about that.
But in terms of what we
think happened, you can never
be sure in evolution you
just make up stories and see
if they fit.
It's more like a murder
mystery and actually a patient
in a coma in an emergency
is the kind of thing
I'm more used to doing actually.
But we think that the CMAH
mutation really occurred
two to three million years ago.
We have some other
connections to the genus homo
that we haven't published yet.
Perhaps there was some
incident or incidents
involving loss of CMAH
and selection of the kind
that we suggested.
And perhaps pathogens and it
turns out that the binding
pockets of the Siglecs, I'm
not showing you the data,
have evolved very rapidly as well.
So maybe there was selection there.
Conclusions-
multiple genomic events
altering hominin and sialic acid
and Siglec biology and there's
and few other sialic acid
changes I've not mentioned,
predate the common ancestor
of humans and Neanderthals.
Actually I don't know of any
other system where there's
been so many changes.
There are likely multiple
selection forces affecting
innate immunity and
host-pathogen interactions.
And perhaps, this is the interesting part,
the secondary consequence
has been human-specific
expression of CD33rSiglecs in
unusual cell types and tissues
including brain, microglere,
mucosal surfaces,
reproductive system,
amnion, placenta, etc.
So I'll leave it there
and say that we have a lot
of work to do.
Encourage others interested
in this area to join us
in this pursuit.
Thank you.
(applause)
(upbeat music)